Roger it's lovely to see you here at MCM
today on the subject of your children
you've both been rather mistreated in
season 5 and season 6 I mean how do you
how does that feel do you think for mace
it's very important question because I
think mace is primary motivation and
everything he does is his family his
children his family he's the state's I
think of these are the things that
matters Mosley and mace hasn't got any
particular ambition to sit on my own
phone I think it's about happy with his
daughter so there and he cares deeply
about his children and will go to any
lengths to make sure those same so it's
been a very important season for that
reason and of course Marjorie's with Tom
and now which was with Joffrey before
but what kind of King do you think
Tommen's gonna make it depends on the
degree to which she's prepared to let
Margaery guide him because I think the
way things are going it's gonna be her
who is the power behind the throne
because he's not sweetly speaking on the
phone she's the concert of the King so I
ain't provided he's prepared to let her
guide him then I think he's gonna be
alright because I cook Marg of being a
good Tyrell he's gonna be very
successful at one point Meryn Trant last
season was talking about tutorials
whether you're in Braavos and he was
saying that when I overheard him saying
that it's rels were all traitors what do
you think about that nonsense rubbish
moulding Trent no anyway these guys
knows nothing about politics he's a fool
on season five of the blu-ray on DVD
commentary writer Bryan cogman was
talking about mesas character and how
he's different from the books and he's
saying that mesas character isn't as
buffoonish as people might think he is
in reality and kind of intimated that
mace might have something a little bit
going on like he's tricking people maybe
a little bit like pycelle or
Littlefinger or virus maybe what's your
thoughts on that I think that's probably
true but unlike the others I suspect
we give anything away but I think it's
probably true that mace is coming is all
directed at keeping his family safe he's
not ambitious in the way that the others
are nor is he petty in the way that the
others are so he's a pretty genuine open
man but is not a fool though I think
we've seen I'd like to film might be
involving mace back at home in
Highgarden because we're never shot
everything there so I'd quite like to
see Highgarden created from the screen
and what would you like to see Game of
Thrones go from here do they
it's such a difficult question you know
that this I'm not being evasive or coy
about it the problem is of course is I
was that tremendous lion in The History
Boys Oh a reminder the history just one
thing after another and it ascends
Westeros the history Westeros made up as
it is is just one thing I know there is
a sense of which you could go on for
forever and it will become a great big
film version of the archers but they're
not gonna let that happen so I think
needs to come to a good conclusion which
I think will mean a good and stable
molecule sitting on the Iron Throne know
who that will be
eh I don't know and be if it did no one
tell you know it's been lovely to talk
to you thank you so much nice to see you
again
you